we had a deal
oh stature you changed the terms of the
deal Modoc
motor come on baby
damn damn oh
don't win that's a Tylenol my friend
oh my God very Doctor Strange so Doctor
Strange so Dr strangee also the world is
giving Star Wars It's I those everything
is heavy Star Wars which is kind of
messed up at following after Andor and
it's like reviews and how great it is
but no one's watching it how dare you
Marvel just make a different Star Wars
property oh my gosh but either way oh my
gosh welcome back to New rockstars you
guys Monday night the final trailer to
quantumania was released giving us our
first look at Modoc new leads to Kings
pass and whether or not Ant-Man is going
out the good guy or the bad guy which
this is inside Marvel uh new Rockstar's
weekly Marvel reaction show I'm Jessica
Clemens and here with me is Mt I cannot
wait for this freaking movie like Kang
is a beast like I cannot wait to see
this massive black man just beat up
is he innocent is he innocent we're
gonna get into it but like also what was
your first reaction where I love this
trailer this trailer was so good it is
incredible like it's just like you can
tell like a lot of these shots were from
like the the third like act of the film
yes yeah but like you could just tell
that like it's gonna be like a huge epic
like like huge Stakes are are on the
line here like you have the entire
Multiverse but you also have Scott and
his family and it's just like I'm so
invested in both it's gonna be amazing
oh I'm so into it before we even jump
into it you guys be sure to head over to
new rockstarsmerch.com where you can
find all of our awesome new rockstars
merch and as we anxiously await the home
release of black panther rakanda forever
there is still time to grab our latest
Obsession shirt the forever King
inspired by the Black Panther sequel
wakanda forever support the channel and
check out all of our awesome merch
options over there at new
rockstarsmerch.com now let's get into it
I kind of want I want to serve you up
this question and then say attack it but
I want you to answer it mainly so he
says in the trailer I can give you one
thing I can give you the one thing you
want time what does that mean I know
that in d23 footage they revealed that
Cassie was like coming out of prison so
in this we do see Cassie Behind Bars it
was definitely Cassie coming out of a
jail sale so is that what he's referring
to by like I can give you time or do you
think it's a bigger picture I think that
Cassie was sentenced to life in prison
for murder and uh she needs to he needs
to break her out but he can't just
kidding no um I think that
um I I think that this is more so having
to deal with the fact that Scott was
trapped to the quantum realm for all
those years and that he didn't get a
chance to grow up with little Cassie and
I think that that's what king is using
against uh Scott he's just like hey look
this is you have this new daughter she's
older she's flawed she got arrested just
like you she's going in your footsteps
don't you miss your little Cassie that
was just like looked up to you wanted to
be your your like your your Sidekick
like she's gone like you saved half the
universe but you still could save little
Cassie because people change because
like she didn't get snapped so like you
know she just changed over time so you
lost that time with Cassie what if I can
get you Cassie back so like I think that
King is potentially dangling like a
little Cassie variants for uh for Scott
he's like hey I can time ice a little
Cassie because I'm okay I can do
anything you guys can't do it but I
can't so that's okay so there's been a
couple things that have been confusing
to me about this and people are talking
about this online because it's like yeah
he can get him that time back but that
doesn't stop the blip so even if he did
spend that time with Cassie does he just
want that time with Cassie and everyone
is still gone he's the one that stopped
the blip basically he's the one that
brought people back like he started it
so it's like if you go back in time
would you just start it sooner are you
are you believing that this man in this
weird Quantum realm can do all of that
for you no I think that after the events
of end game
um like they all like all the The
Avengers started mingling and then Scott
probably saw Peter quails and Gamora
he's like yo you gotta you're you're the
person that you lost back by doing some
weird time travel stuff why can't I grab
my little Cassie from another different
timeline and like bring her to my
timeline so I can have two Cassies in
one timeline that'd be just great two
likes and that was right but that can
you probably yeah I can do it because I
can do whatever I want that's insane
that is insane if Scott goes along with
that I will think he's dumber than what
he is
um
in the nicest way it's all about like
Despair and grief like people do crazy
things for grief as we've seen one
division so that's why I think that
Cassie's actually the one that first
dies so I think I think someone's not
only gonna die and I think it's gonna be
Cassie oh yeah literally middle of the
film maybe earlier into the film she's
gonna die he's gonna kill her and he's
gonna be like I can bring her back if
you do one thing for me and he's gonna
be like I'll do anything and that's why
we see that scene where Janet's like you
don't understand he is a chaos bringer
and he's just like you have your child
and your husband been I have nothing my
child is now gone and I will do anything
to get her back so I think that time is
the main I think time is like I can give
you more time with your daughter I can
give I can bring her back because I can
change time I can't like I can't like
make her a zombie or like bring her back
from the dead but I can go back into I
can move time back to get her
um but I also do believe that part where
it's like yeah Cassie was in prison all
this stuff was happening you want that
time back and now oh actually this
actually gets into our second question I
I like what you brought up about um like
Cassie potentially dying because we know
in the comics that Cassie I think had a
heart problem or like some type of like
sickness that that made her terminally
ill so like there could be another that
could be another angle of like I can
give you more time like I can save
Cassie where like I can give you the big
antidote or whatever so like there's
different angles to that for sure what
if he genuinely is like I know your
daughter's dying like I know I I know
your daughter's dying you don't know yet
but I do and it's like right that would
be that'd be crazy horrific that would
be horrible but I do think I believe
that Cassie's gonna be the first one to
die she'll be brought back don't get me
wrong but she's gonna be the first one
to die and it's gonna be that because we
need that justification of like I agree
with Janet from the trailer about what
she says like please don't trust this
man there has to be and I believe that
Scott is smart enough to know not to
trust this crazy man in the middle of a
Quantum realm but I think something so
bad happened that he has to put he has
to lay down like he has to be able to
submit to it and I think it's just
Cassie dying I think it's Cassie dying
oh that would be crazy that would be too
dark I'd be sad well she'll be brought
back and she's not and the thing is they
can do it because she's not necessarily
a child like the person the woman
playing her is a woman great
job
Disney said the closest we'll get is
we'll make them sort of evaporate and we
won't they will be off screen
when the blip happened and all of
Peter's like students like evaporated on
the basketball court oh yeah or unless
it's a Star Wars uh unless they're gonna
show the uh Anakin's Betrayal they'll
show that all day they're like oh yeah
it's perfectly fine
but first we want to thank the folks
that bring inside Marvel to you guys
people like nordvpn we love these people
nor VPN are amazing Partners we watch a
lot of movies and series here in new
rock stars and one thing that makes that
easier is nordvpn with nordvpn you can
change your virtual location with just
one click which makes it easier to find
streaming platforms at a lower price we
can even access platforms that are
available in the United States like
hacking it's amazing magic with just one
click you can choose with from over 5400
servers in over 60 countries that way we
never miss out on our favorite content
whether we are at home or traveling and
if you're worried that nordvpn might
cause buffering when you're watching
content don't worry about that norvpn
has got that juice it provides amazing
speed thanks to Nord links so you can
stream securely without bandwidth
throttling we don't like that we like to
have smooth internet nor vpn's benefits
and features go Way Beyond improving
your streaming experience you can also
access games and discounts only
available in other regions in Block
malware written websites while you
explore securely we encourage you to try
nordvpn for yourself so grab your
exclusive nordvpn deal by going to
nordvpn.com Marvel to get a huge
discount off your nordvpn plan plus four
additional months for free period for
free it's free it is amazing I love free
it's completely risk-free with nord's
30-day money-back guarantee that's Nord
n-o-r-d-vpn.com Marvel for an exclusive
discount plus four months free perfect
and I want to get you into Helix sleep
whether you are traveling around the
quantum realm battling the forces trying
to destroy our world or just going about
your regular daily life you could use a
good night's sleep everyone deserves a
good night's sleep and here on new rock
stars We Trust Helix to protect our
sleep with the best mattress in the
world we both have Helix mattresses me
and Mt and we love them can't get enough
of them Helix sleep has a quiz that
takes just two minutes to complete and
matches your body type and sleep
purposes to perfect mattresses for you
and that is very important because you
don't want to wake up with a kink in
your neck every day everybody's unique
and Helix knows that so they have
several different mattress models to
choose from they have soft medium and
firm mattresses mattress is great for
cooling you down if you sleep super hot
like myself
mattress is great for spinal alignment
to prevent morning aches and pains and
even a helix plus mattress for plus size
sleepers like myself I can't get enough
of my Helix mattress I jump on it like
the monkeys on the bed fall off crack my
head uh what about you empty oh yeah my
Helix mattress is a gift from the gods I
love it so much it's amazing it's
perfect if I didn't have it honestly I'd
probably lose my mind so just go to
helixsleep.com inside Marvel take their
two minute sleep quiz and they'll match
you to the customized mattress that will
give you the best sleep of your life I
promise you they have a 10 year warranty
and you get to try it out for a hundred
nights risk for you guys you can return
it that's insane Helix is offering up to
200 off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com inside Marvel go to Turbo
Tax and don't do your taxes meet with an
expert who'll do them for you Turbo Tax
experts can relieve you from the stress
of taxes and file for you so you can do
not taxes show your eyes things that are
not taxes unpack a moving box of not
taxes taste not taxes seeing not tax is
a lullaby hope not taxes sleeps through
the night grab a saddle and ride not
taxes into the sunset with TurboTax an
expert will do your taxes from start to
finish ensuring your taxes are done
right guaranteed so you can relax feels
good to be done with your taxes doesn't
it come to Turbo Tax and don't do your
taxes visit turbotax.com to learn more
into it Turbo Tax full service products
only video meeting while expert does
your taxes required see guaranteed
details at turbotax.com guarantees so
second question for inside Marvel what
deal did Ant-Man make and also why
didn't he serve up that deal for Janet
so big picture wise right Scott was in
prison had a hard time even hanging out
with Cassie he was stuck during the blip
she's now in prison he's famous I get
all he wants is time you guys but what
kind of deal did he make and also why
didn't Janet get the same deal
um this is true this is true like this
is I mean they are both shrinking people
they're both really good at what they do
so like why didn't Kang approach Janet
as well because we don't we don't know
how long she was in there technically
right in Quantum realm time wise we
don't know if it'd been decades right
well outside it's been decades but
inside right God knows how long she
could be like as like hundreds of years
old we don't know how the quantum realm
affects your physiology because we know
that she was completely different like
she could freaking heal people with her
weird energy powers in the second movie
so like we don't know exactly if she
spent hundreds of years down there like
she could be like a huge like super old
being for all you know even though
Michelle Pfeiffer is looks really great
that's just on Michelle P that's just
Michelle P yeah that's just good do you
think that uh Kane gave her those
abilities and maybe she made a deal with
Kang to get that sort of ability that we
still don't really know necessarily she
was just able to stabilize ghost so I
don't we I don't really know what her
power is outside of the quantum realm
but do you think it's something that
Kane gave her I think that it could
possibly be
to like that weird energy source that
they seem to be going after that weird
like yellow
um source that Ant-Man and his weird
clones are seeming to grab and I think
that her exposure to that type of
radiation was like absorbed into her
being and so like she just was she just
had that in her she's like all right I
just have this ability to to have this
radiation within me because like I've
been dealing with this and I don't know
to what capacity I feel like you know
since she's a scientist she probably
continued being a scientist in the
quantum realm and I was was working on
you know heart or understanding Quantum
um energy and Quantum technology and
continuing our research that she was
doing with um with Hank down there so
like maybe
um she just was at a different facility
a different research facility that she
was um exposed to all that radiation
from but who knows but no that's a good
question like why didn't Janet get that
same deal like is I wonder if her and
Kang
um are even friends or like she seems to
not trust King so like what is their
history there like what do you think 100
I also think so like going off of her
being a scientist I think she worked
closely more closely closer to Bill
Murray's character and the sit like that
Citadel that they have so I think she's
working closer to him probably as a
scientist and there has been times where
she has had the chance an opportunity to
meet with Kang and Kang's like hey let's
work together and she's like no I'm not
gonna trust you and that's the
difference between her and Scott is
Scott has something on the line she
didn't really she was like I'm stuck in
this Quantum realm just like you are
like we're both stuck in here I can't
get out so I think Janet didn't have
anything on the line for her to say yes
and make a deal with King but I think
Scott does I oh my God I just I can't
wait to see Janet in this movie I'm I'm
wondering if like you know I mean Kang
is Kang like Kang is a conqueror so like
yeah there's a good chance that she has
seen Kang do like war crimes
oh no don't trust this man 100 this is
terrible literally literally so do we
believe that overall the deal that he
made with Ant-Man was I'll give you more
time with Cassie in exchange for a
device that gets me out of the quantum
realm yeah essentially I think that he
he needs Scott to steal something very
very crucial to his plan to invade the
timelines with that huge Army and he's
just like hey I'm gonna give you time
with Cassie because you have the like
the weird imagination and the know-how
to do impossible Heist like you did the
uh like the craziest Heist of all time
you do the Time Heist he probably thinks
God is like the coolest because like you
didn't I I had never met anyone in
history that's ever done a Time Ice so
like you are my man
um and like since like we know that
Modoc uh freaking
um yellow jacket from the first film is
uh partners with King modoc's probably
like hey
um you know what's a really good idea
get this guy down here that I hate so I
can freaking have my revenge on him
bring bring Scott Lang down here so I
can beat him up with my big ass head but
yes
just one
[Music]
so that kind of goes to our next
question this one yeah we'll keep kind
of brief so we can save it for the
fourth Quest the fourth question for
more meaty dialogue what are Kang's
abilities and how do they differ outside
the quantum realm so Janet says uh he
can rewrite existence and shatter
timelines so I guess like that's a big
deal so how does it differ from the big
screen to the comics right so we know in
the comics he has time travel time
manipulation which transfers to this now
and unarmed he's really good at unarmed
Camp combat he's built his suit with
Force blasters he also commands a ton of
Warriors across the Galaxy which all of
this seems like it's transferring into
the big screen so is this Kang basically
set up to be the king for Kang's Dynasty
see that's that's the big question I
feel I feel like with this movie
Anything could happen because like we
could see like the defeat of this King
by Ant-Man and like it's like yeah we
beat the bad guy in the film but then
one like one of the Kings get loose
under the timeline or a couple Kings get
loose and then that's our our big big
bad king
um but you know I think it'd be really
cool if this
um quantumania Kang did win at the end
of this movie
um and like like maybe like the Ant-Man
team stops a bigger threat like maybe he
they destroy the Army leaving King by
himself but like I would really love if
Kang
um is that same one in King Dynasty but
what what do you think I I think I I
hope I hope so much that I do believe it
because I think this Kang is the king
the Conqueror that we see through the
like the the main King that we've seen
and I think I don't want to see him get
thrown away so quickly so I think this
king will be the big bad I think even
with Loki when uh he who remains said
you should see the other evil versions
of myself I think this was one of of the
most ultimate evils that got banished to
literally a realm where he cannot get
out like I'm sure there was other Realms
that he could have got out of and they
were like this one though for some
reason he can't get out of it so I think
this will be our big bad that takes us
all the way to the end of phase six I
think this is also the opening to show
how easily he can like persuade people
so I think it's like we're gonna see him
build a team and be like why is it so
easy for him to build people and build a
team and then it's gonna be like he's
gonna start making armies he's gonna
start making armies everywhere everybody
bro I'm telling you like um what's it
called what's the actor's name from uh a
good place the Harper Jackson Williams
Williams I know who you're talking about
from the good place Yeah well yeah that
that amazing actor I'm really bad with
the name sometimes I'm so sorry um
William Jackson Harper probably yeah
um and I think that he's gonna be a king
variant I think that he's going to be
um either like a younger version of Kang
or he's going to be a okay that's going
to be moving on to different projects
like potentially uh Vision Quest maybe
it's Victor timely because we know
Victor timely gang from the comics was
really into robotics so like there it
could be the Victor timely King it could
be the Scarlet Centurion who um in the
in the King Dynasty run
um Kang invades the timeline with his
son
um Marcus
um and so we could be looking at that
actor being a Marcus
um his son who it was actually like
clones or whatever
that's a weird thing do you think the
age difference is there between Jonathan
majors and the guy from the good place
they kind of look the same I mean like
jump the name Majors isn't like super
super old but like he is old in the MCU
so like sure that's true he has probably
found a way to preserve his youth so
like he probably has a son that is
around his age visually
um by now
um I think that's likely annoying take
what if he is because isn't fair Kang
that is a variant oh that's Nathaniel
Richards or am I thinking right it's
there's the implication that uh King the
Conqueror is a descendant of Nathaniel
Richards or something like that and like
which one I don't think it's ever been
confirmed was it the Iron Man then there
was one that was like a little kid that
was like I don't want to be king but I'm
gonna be good no it was I don't know
Iron lad is he too old to be Iron lad
I see that's okay I was thinking that
earlier today
um I think that he might be too old to
be Iron lad because he's a full-grown
man
um I think it'd be really fun because
like we we do have uh you know Haley
Seinfeld and the Young Avengers and like
we like so like she is an adult herself
so like I can see them being like Oh
yeah maybe you could have like an adult
iron line but I think with the name like
iron lad we're probably gonna see a
teenage iron lad uh probably closer to
the age of um Isaiah Bradley's grandson
um I'm assuming uh my favorite thing in
the world is if we went into a different
dimension or time and we see older iron
lad and it's him and he's just like yeah
I used to be called iron lad but not
anymore he's just like an old man not
anymore I was sort of gonna make a video
about this but like I think that Kang is
Loki obsessed with with Iron Man and you
can sort of see it in this trailer with
like you when he removes the blue from
his um from his face that's basically
the end game technology
um that they had
um for their masks their their Nani
technology and like I just feel and like
he shoots blast out of his hands yeah he
has the same thing I just have a feeling
that this dude's just a huge and like we
know that like um he goes into iron land
in the Young Avengers so like I just
feel like he's a huge Stan he's like I'm
Tony Stark is the coolest guy that's why
I think ironline is going to be
appearing in iron heart I want it to
happen I want it to happen and I want to
be crazy I want him to have helped
either Cassie or to help uh Dominic
Thorne's character one of the two okay
I've bring them in bring them in so our
fourth and final question or just
talking about Modoc we all let me do
this
we all saw yes and we all saw him and I
will say it here because I said it on
Twitter you guys he looks like the comic
book Modoc there is no way to transfer
this modak into looking something that's
not in that he will always look
ridiculous because he's a big faced big
head tiny limbed body that's all he is
he has all had no torso nothing
get back to Dad and you guys are like
why do they do that to him and I'm like
that's what he looks like either way we
know that it is Darren cross we know
that it's Darren cross which we last saw
in the original Ant-Man film the first
one where he's trapped inside the yellow
suit jacket he got shrunk down and we
were like okay bye and now he is a Modoc
and it's different from the original
Source material he has said a little bit
but it is still Modoc and uh I would get
into his origin and all that stuff but
Tommy actually has a video that drops on
Tuesday that dropped on Tuesday breaking
down Modoc in his origin so just go
check that out either way Janet's been
in there for decades and did it change
when she came out so why does Moda
Darren cross look like this
why is he why is it I
but like the moment where he gets
crushed and supposedly dies but actually
disappears into the quantum realm like
is these limbs get like crushed inwards
in like you know he like you could sort
of see like the justification it's like
all right he has tiny limbs in his head
is like is his Limbs and head
proportions are really all bad
um greats right now because of the way
that he got crushed so um I think that
Kang probably saved him potentially
where he's just like oh man this guy's
like he he managed to recreate the pen
particle like I I need this man's
knowledge of you know Quantum technology
um Quantum energy and all that stuff to
help me with my Endeavor so he Partners
up with him by Saving his life and
making the uh machine only designed for
killing I forget the machine only
designed yeah it's for up or something
oh killing uh Modoc
um so yeah I think it's I think it makes
sense and like from other what if
episodes
um what it's what if zombie episodes
that like it is possible for a head to
exist without like to exist on its for
as the primary organ I guess I should
say because he doesn't have like a body
a little tiny body but like Scott Lang
was a had a head in the Zombies episode
and they were just carrying that around
so it's possibly up to you do we think I
guess what is his role in this movie and
do we think we could see him team up
with Scott Lang instead of against
Scotland it looks like from the images
that we or the video that we saw he's
always standing behind Kang so it looks
like he's a little minion to Kang like a
little Little Helper but do we think
that he could switch sides or do we or
what is he doing in this film overall I
think that this is
the beginnings of modoc's involvement in
the MCU I think that by the end of this
film we're going to see him make it out
of a Quantum realm in back into the real
world and potentially partnering up with
Val and like helping her with whatever
she's doing oh I I think that he's going
to serve as like a really big antagonist
in this movie in the sense that like he
probably like um orchestrated the events
of the the whole kidnapping of the Lang
family like I mentioned before but
specifically through
um he knows how valuable Cassie is to
Scott and Cassie is sending these
signals to the quantum realm
communicating with like I don't know
some type of pen pal that she doesn't
know about and like he's like oh shoot
it's Cassie Lang the girl that I
kidnapped and had a huge Tom the Tank
Engine fight for yeah let me try to take
her again so I think that he's gonna be
like the main well he's not gonna do
that like King's the main villain but
he's gonna be the secret like yes it's
my plan that ruined your life Scott I
agree with that I agree with that but I
think when he gets to the out of the
quantum realm if he does I he's going to
be playing such a minor he's going to do
and by minor I think he's gonna head up
the intelligencia he's going to reform
the intelligencia now Todd's gone
um I yes we know from the comics that he
was a part of it but I think he's gonna
like take control of it we also like
know that they've brought up Aim so I'm
like at what point are we just gonna
make another aim and he's gonna be the
head of it so I think that will start
once he comes out and tries to be his
own bad team I don't think he's gonna
work under king forever but I do think
he's gonna start initiating bigger moves
and fighting maybe like the Young
Avengers oh yeah I think that sword is a
huge huge spot where we could see what
do you think being installed because we
saw from One Division that like the the
workers sort of had that that b sort of
a beekeeper sort of motif going on there
and that's the huge motif of the uh the
uh the incorporation so I can see Kang
being maybe secretly erected as a leader
of the sword Organization for uh for Val
and like sort of like making aim
um or adopting uh or taking over I guess
Aldrich Killian's aim from that I don't
know this is gonna be some weird we're
gonna say this is not the end we're
gonna see a Modoc there's so many things
that you can do with Modoc put him put
him a sword anything I can't wait for
him to show up and then him to meet the
leader and then him and the leader
become yes Co bad people together
they're gonna be working together
Modoc together is a dangerous
combination into the future yes yes keep
going I was like that though yes yes
it's gonna be bad it's gonna be bad it's
gonna be the leader and Modoc going
against the Thunderbolts and it'll be so
much fun it'll be so much fun it might
even be worse than that we could see the
leader of the Modoc we see The Return of
claw we could see like the entire dude
Zemo shows up the entire Zemo huge like
it's like we can see a whole like
Injustice League of like you know super
villains show up and I think that that
might be the plan here I love this I
love this you guys but you know I I
cannot wait either it's gonna be an
amazing movie but that is it for this
episode of inside Marvel don't forget to
check out our many many amazing great
merch options over at New
rockstarsmerch.com and if you're over 18
click the link in the description for
the new rockstars Discord server and
join the conversation today you can
follow uh Jessica at Lulu Clemens you
can follow me at mastertonment you can
subscribe to inside Marvel wherever you
get your podcast thank you guys so much
for watching we love you guys times a
million we'll see you guys next time
goodbye bye
foreign
[Music]